مسموع
جيم مطنوخ الروح
[موسيقى]
من جديد وللمره الثانيه صواريخ موسكو
تخترق ستار نيتو وتنتهيك اجوائه في رساله
مرعبه ومكون يسحب وسام الشرف من الرئيس
الروسي بوتين وجورجيا ميلودي الروس
يباغتون الاتحاد الاوروبي ويغلقون شريان
الطاقه واشنطن تقترح الارض مقابل السلام
لايقاف الحرب الاوكرانيه فهل يتحقق ذلك
المنطاد الصيني يكشف عورات امريكا وجسم
اخر يحلق في اجواء الولايات المتحده
وواشنطن ترد على الصين برساله نوويه زلزال
تركيا وسوريا يواصل حصد الارواح وبين
الامل والياس شعره فهل تنقطع خلال الساعات
والايام القادمه زوجه زعيم كوريا الشماليه
تتزين بصاروخ عابر للقارات فكيف ذلك
والفلسطينيون يوجه صفعه مميته للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وبعد تنبؤه بزلزال تركيا
المدمر العالم الهولندي يتوقع زلزالا اخر
في ثلاث دول عربيه
موسكو تتحرك بحلف النيتو بعض الرسائل لا
تصل بالكلام ولا يكفي التهديد والتحذير
ليرسل الرسل رسائل اخرى للنيتو وعلى
الطريقه
الخاصه وهنا مجددا وللمره الثانيه يعلنها
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
روسيين من طراز
مجال الجوي لمولدوفا ثم عبر المجال الجوي
الروماني قبل دخول اوكرانيا وفقا لوكاله
رويترز صواريخ الروسيه اذا تتبختر في سماء
اعضاء النيتو وبوتين يوصل رسالته للحلف
بعبور تلك الصواريخ ثم عودتها نحو
اوكرانيا اليكم انه لا يمكن تحت اي ظرف ان
يتم تسليمها في الاسابيع القليله المقبله
اضاف الجيش الاوكراني ان عده صواريخ روسيه
اخترقت اجواء رومانيا وملتوفا ليست ذلك
فقط بل ان روسيا جنت هجوما واسعا من
الصواريخ والطائرات المسيره المتفجره التي
استهدفت عددا من مواقع الطاقه في اوكرانيا
بعد جوله
في اوروبا وامريكا للمطالبه بمزيد من
الاسلحه في رساله روسيه اخرى وهذه المره
للاتحاد الاوروبي منذ فردت على صواريخ
موسكو على استحياء حيث استدعت السفير
الروسيه لديها على خلفيه اختراق مجالها
الجوي حسب فرنسي بريس لتاخذ ايطاليا دور
المنتقد للاوروبيين بدلا عن روسيا حيث
انتقدت رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه
الاجتماع الفرنسيه الالماني
معتبرت ميلون
غير مناسب بحسب موقع تعز شو الالماني
لتعود وتوجه انتقادها مباشره نحو الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل بسبب مادوبه العشاء التي
استضاف فيها نظيره الاوكراني
وصفه لاجتماع الرئيسين في باريس بانه خطا
سياسي لكن مكون لا يلتفت لتحذيرات ويعلن
منح نظيره الاوكراني وسام جوقه الشرف رئيس
الفرنسي لا يكتفي بذلك ويقول انه ينتظر
الوقت المناسب لسحب وسام الشرف الفرنسي من
نظيره الروسي لاديمير بوتين فكيف سيرد
بوتين ومن توترات الحرب الى طاوله السلام
حيث كانت صحيفه
قالت لنا رئيس وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه عرض في منتصف يناير من هذا
العام على
خطه للتسويه شمال التخليه اوكرانيا عن 20%
من اراضيه لصالح روسيا مقابل السلام ليرد
اليوم مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ميخائيل
بقوله انك لم تتلقى اي مقترح للسلام بمبدا
الارض مقابل السلام
لن تتنازل عن اراضيها التي سيطرت عليها
روسيا اما روسيا فردت على لسان المتحدث
باسم الكرملين
[موسيقى]
وبناء على الوقائع الجديده القائمه على
الارض يقولها الروس باختصار ما وضعنا
ايدينا عليه اصبح ملكا لنا يا نهار اسود
ومنيل لينطلق الروس نحو حرب اخرى لكن مع
القاره الاوروبيه هذه المره ردا على تحديد
سقفا لاسعار النفط الروسي قال نائب رئيس
الوزراء الروسي الكسندر نوفاك ان موسكو
تعتزم خفض انتاجها النفطي طواعيه بمقدار
500 الف برميل يوميا في مرسى المقبل في
ماكد الرئيس الصربيه الكساندر فوتشي ان
بلاده قد تضطر لفرض عقوبات على روسيا بسبب
الضغوط الغربيه عليها
بكين تضرب
وواشنطن ترد
الاستخبارات تعمل على قدم وساق الاقمار
الصناعيه ترصد والرادارات لا تتوقف وهذا
هو حال الامريكان في الوقت الحالي يراقبون
كل حركه وسكنه للصين وادواتها وبعد ازمه
المنطاد الصيني هو البيت الابيض يعلن ان
واشنطن اسقط جسما طائرا بحجم سياره صغيره
حلق على عدو مرتفع فوق الاسكا بناء على
اوامر الرئيس جو بايدن لتعيش الولايات
المتحده قلقا غير مسبوق لا يعلمون من اين
يتجسس عليهم اصحاب العيون الضيق هنا تحركت
واشنطن للرد على بكين لتكشف القوات
الامريكيه عن اطلاق صاروخ باليستين عابر
للقارات فيما وصف بانه استعراض للردع
النووي اظهر دقه وموثوقيه نظام الصواريخ
الامريكيه البالستيه العابره للقارات في
رساله واضحه للصين بعد قضيه المنقاد
الصيني وبالعوده لازمه المنطاد ولا مسؤول
كبير في الخارجيه الامريكيه يؤكد ان
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه قد ارسلت مناطيد او
بالونات المراقبه فوق اكثر من 40 دوله في
خمس قارات مشيرا الى ان اداره بايدن
تتواصل مع البلدان مباشره حول نطاق هذا
البرنامج والاجابه على اي اسئله بحسب موقع
الحره
امل يختفي تحت الانقاض
الرعب لم ينتهي القلق يستمر القهر يملا
القلوب والقلوب قد بلغت الحناجر صمت مطبق
وتعابير الالم والحزن هي من تتحدث وبين
ركام كل هذه المشاعر وبين حطام الزلزال
يكمن بصيص امل قد ينقطع مع مضي الساعات
وبعد اكثر من 120 ساعه ينقطع الامل رويدا
رويدا ويزداد الياس بوجود ناجين تحت
الانقاض لكن هنا يخرج هذا الرجل وهو يتلو
القران الكريم بعد ان امضى اكثر من 140
ساعات تحت الانقاض فيان قلبه الخاشع وهنا
صلاه الفجر تنقذ اللاعب الكاميروني كيف
نسوني لاعب
الزلزال ليقول سوني ان بقائه على قيد جاء
بسبب انتظاره لصلاه الفجر ذلك اليوم
لننتقل الى مشهد مؤثر لاب تركي يبحث عن
اولاده تحت الانقاض بعد زلزال تركيا ووسط
ياس وبكاء الاب تتعالى صيحاته تجار كان
لعله يجد بصيص امل بنجاتهم بيالهم من موقف
يقطر القلب دما امامه في سوريا قال مدير
الدفاع المدني انه تم الانتهاء من عمليات
البحث والانقاذ وحانت مرحله البحث وانتشال
الجثث مضيفا انه لم يدخل اي فريق انقاذ
دولي الى شمال غربي سوريا وان الامم
المتحده لم تقدم شيء
الاحداث والتطورات
زوجه الزعيم الكوري الشمالي تظهر وهي
ترتدي قلاده على شكل اكبر صاروخ باليستي
عابر بالقارات في البلاد السيده ريسو ظهرت
مبتسمه والقلاده تحيط بعنقها على مادبه
طعام رفقه زوجها
وحولهم قاده عسكريون وفق الصحيفه تيليجرا
في البريطانيه الهجمات الفرديه الفلسطينيه
ترعب الكيان الاسرائيلي ليتعدى الرد
الاسرائيلي منفذي العمليات الى ذويهم
وبعد عمليه الداس التي نفذها الشاب
الفلسطيني ليحصد قتيلين واربعه مصابين
اسرائيليين في محطه حافلات بالقدس وزير
الامن القومي للكيان اتمار بن غفير يامر
شرطه الاحتلال باعداد خطه لتنفيذ عمليه
[موسيقى]
بينما انطلق الضربات جويه متبادله بين
اسرائيل والمقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه
والجيش الاسرائيلي يولين اعتراض القبه
الحديديه لصاروخ اطلق من القطاع بعد تنبؤه
بزلزال تركيا المدمر العالم الهولندي
فرانكو
في مصر والعراق ولبنان اوروبا تراقب
صواريخ بوتين بقلق والولايات المتحده لا
تغمض اعينها امام ادوات الصين التجسسيه
والعالم يصوبون نظره نحو ضحايا الزلزال في
تركيا وسوريا والمستقبل مجهول لهذه
المعموره
[موسيقى]